what's up folks it's Friday yeah this is
the daily report right Jenny actually
she went out she went to the damn post
off I did go to the post office cuz
somebody bought something I forgot that
I had a bunch of [ __ ] up on sale on eBay
how'd it look out there um not too bad
it's like there's still people driving
around the traffic is notably lighter
than it would be like normally in a
weekday probably because you know kids
aren't in school and whatnot but it
didn't really look all that different
like even when I went in the hitches
touch my face but um yeah so I when I
went to the post office it looked pretty
normal and abnormal I mean it's the
parking lots all they were everybody was
at the grocery store and everything look
normal
yeah actually the Publix parking lot
looked full yeah but we haven't been
there for several days so I don't know
like how empty the [ __ ] has rendered the
show Sophie Sophie Benjamin since she
sent screenshots cents shots off her
phone of the damn grocery store in
Michigan she was at his [ __ ] empty
bear just bare bones it was scaring her
I could tell she's like look there's no
chicken looked at it's just the whole
aisles I was showing Jenny whole empty
aisles but that's just panic buying
they're making food for common I was
just reading an article earlier today
and I think the Wall Street Journal did
an article as well that was saying like
what all these like food companies are
doing like to get the food out faster so
they're even there they put on people
over time they're hiring people like
even people like dominos and stuff like
that is hiring people just like yeah the
demand is just strangely this might be
really good for the economy well I don't
know if it's gonna be good for the
economy but they aren't certain
industries are probably making money
yeah they said actually some industries
like Sam's obviously Costco fast food
places where you can get drive-through
Starbucks McDonald's they're actually
making about 20% more than this same
week last year yeah just because
everyone's staying in so they're
ordering you know takeout yeah guys like
that guns ammo any kind of [ __ ] gun
accessories fire shooting were
stuff and you know us is [ __ ] through
the roof I was looking at online stores
a lot of just sold out everybody's
buying everything they think it's gonna
be another Katrina so they want to they
want to make sure that their security
needs are met because which you know
find is a lot a lot of [ __ ] that people
are buying like I said that a biter
buying yeah they're just buying because
I think what happens is that when
something of this magnitude happens you
feel like you don't have any control
which you don't I mean to a large extent
so I think it makes you feel better to
cut my own ass to go out and buy a bunch
of stuff well if I have I need chicken
and I need this and that I need toilet
paper I totally understand it man we
were buying early I saw the ship coming
we got we got a lot of our [ __ ] well the
thing about us is that we didn't know go
I didn't go out and buy [ __ ] nine
cases of toilet paper no and people are
still asking like I said I joined an
Orlando area Facebook group where
everybody is like hey if you go out and
you see where you know toilet paper and
[ __ ] is like tell people because some
people are still looking around for it
it what's funny is that they're buying
it up faster than they're using their
stockpile in it that's what I mean
there's nothing is that like places like
Costco and stuff like that they're
making it so that if you bought like a
shit-ton you can't like take it back you
get like store credit after this whole
[ __ ] thing because they're like hey
your [ __ ] it's yours
yeah and and also eBay and maybe Amazon
I'm not sure but II Bay's been cracking
down on people they're charging like
[ __ ] fifty or hundred dollars for
acting like there's more people there
isn't more people you don't need that's
I mean everyone's just flipping out yeah
there isn't more people the demand is
exactly the same it's just that they're
buying it up faster than they're
delivering it yeah for silly reasons but
yeah like this is when the shelves go
dry then they think it's oh we got to
buy it oh it will vanish yeah they're
probably buying [ __ ] they don't even
like they don't gonna eat ya in a couple
weeks at all that's what I mean like I
said your big food companies you know
that packaged the food and send it out
and stuff have actually added more
people have added more over time they're
cross-training people on different jobs
so that they can like you know not have
to so they so they have more [ __ ] going
on and because a lot of restaurants are
kind of
curtailed what they started doing I was
reading about some companies that you
know packaged stuff for restaurants and
they packaged stuff for you know like
grocery stores and stuff they said so
they're kind of taking a lot of stuff
off the line for restaurants and they're
pre and they're repackaging it in
smaller portions so they can get them
sent out all these Indian restaurants
that we like only Chinese restaurants
you know they need to start doing
takeout bigger than [ __ ] well they do
I mean you can do takeout and most of
them have started doing delivery as well
or like I said even if they don't if
they're still open Fifth Element didn't
have takeout um you can try order you
could probably order everybody most most
places will do takeout it's just I don't
know because that wasn't really their
main business but even if they don't
have delivery drivers of their own I
mean obviously you can call grumpy over
ever eats or whatever like that like I
said yes it's people touching your food
but it's like you can't avoid touching
your food when they make it they're
touching your food you make it it's like
you can't avoid people forever like I
said the mailman had to touch your [ __ ]
like to bring it to your mailbox so it's
like just come and they're overreacting
because the [ __ ] is not that deadly it's
not that deadly I mean for some people
it will be yeses you have to be careful
because you don't know if people are
compromising whatever for the main
populace though it's like maybe two or
three percent fatal and it's certain
demographics yeah and like I said if
you're in the demographic that has to
worry about it yeah then everybody else
should be looking out for you and trying
not to like probably half of this will
get it you know it's it's like don't
it's just like don't do dumb [ __ ] like
don't go out and then and wipe your nose
and touch everything and [ __ ] like that
just be careful yeah I mean you know so
that's that's kind of where we are like
I said I haven't been to the grocery
store for several days so I just I just
went to the post office
today to mail something and it seemed
not really that weird it's like yes the
traffic is a little bit lighter but it's
kind of like what traffic is like in the
summertime like when kids are out of
school yeah you know what I mean it kind
of looks like that I've said this a
couple times before on the other show
I just want to say it again and think is
something shit's not gonna go back to
normal
it probably won't like I said um you
know it's it's kind of sucks for like a
lot of businesses that won't bounce back
but I do it's weird to me how I mean I
guess like I said because everything has
been going you know going anyways online
anyway it's really amazing to me how
quickly like a lot of businesses adapted
to you know like I saw just before we
started recording like even like
non-essential [ __ ] like you know
Michael's like the craft store and stuff
they're like they've already established
hey order [ __ ] through our app and you
know we'll put it outside and you just
come pick a like herb side pick up so
you don't have to come in the store and
you don't tell like interact with people
and [ __ ] like that society and life is
like a process of natural selection and
what's gonna happen is that these
companies that were having trouble I'm
gonna be forced to adapt and they're
gonna find out that the overheads are
less if they just run an app and deliver
and if they get rid of brick-and-mortar
or cut brick-and-mortar way down and do
search so so they won't go back to
normal
they're gonna find out that well you
know it's cheaper to do this way we made
more money when we do it that way and
most people like will yeah leave my
house right most people don't like
that's what's gonna happen you know
that's what's gonna have it's just it
sucks if you have to leave your house
and you know what I mean they're already
trying to figure out well that's more
efficient so that means there's less
jobs out there so they're trying to come
up with that ubi the universal basic
income Trump called Yang in there
they're gonna try to figure that out
because technology is gonna make a bunch
of people obsolete and if they're not
buying anything that will topple
civilization so you have to have people
who want work and have an ability to buy
well yeah yeah and they have to yeah
they have to have some kind of well and
they have money to pay bills and stuff
like that or they'll start stealing [ __ ]
well yeah as anyone well here's the
thing there's the thing though they
don't they give a [ __ ] about that they
give a [ __ ] about what happens to an
individual person they only care about
what happens to their industries yeah I
know and if their customers all go
vanish their industry vanishes yeah so
paying people basically that universal
basic income is the same as paying
themselves because they know that
they're you're gonna spend it and give
the money back to them anyway yeah so to
keep the money flowing they're gonna do
that
yeah I can tell you they're gonna do
nobody can buy [ __ ] if AI and robots
will replace so many people you know
what I mean what what are people gonna
do yeah you know and you're not gonna be
able to put that you're not gonna be
able to put that on that on the taxpayer
because the only people paying taxes are
the middle class the rich don't pay
taxes and the poor don't pay taxes and
the middle class can't afford to pay for
that because the middle class are
striking so where's this money gonna
come from I take it from Wall Street I'd
make like a a half a percentage transit
transaction tax on every one of those
Rock Wall Street transactions we got
supercomputers and they'd probably be
able to pull so much money out of the
damn wall street name funny like I said
they need to take it from people that
can [ __ ] afford it that's well yeah
this guy's mom Wall Street just they
can't take it from my ass cuz I've got
it
Wall Street's really nothing but just an
electronic casino really yeah so I just
there'd be a waste there'd be waste
there's a lot of money out there the
working people don't have it well but
there's a lot of money out there that
yeah that can and you got to keep it
circulating if not the whole house of
cards falls so there's no choice that's
what I mean it's like I I do feel like
you know your big ol one-percenters and
stuff like that they kind of forget it's
like you're sitting on top of a mountain
here and all this mountain is all these
like [ __ ] four people if all these
poor people are gone you're gonna yeah
the way no people can't send that money
upward well it's asserts its circulation
like like blood circulating through a
body you know and the problem is is that
a lot of that Bloods being sent out of
the country and then it goes into like
global corporations and it's
disseminated and then it sometimes kind
of flows back it's just the system is
gonna have to [ __ ] change but yeah
what I was what I was reading earlier
because you know I was reading an
article about there's there's a blog
called the takeout which I really looked
just like a food-related blog because
I'm like really interested in like food
you know culturally and kind of history
of food and stuff like that and they
were kind of trying to see both sides of
the issue it's like should you get
takeout or not in the sense that yes
you're putting people at risk like from
the virus like making them come to your
house and making them come to work and
you know
potentially passing the virus on but
then in another sense if you don't get
takeout from these restaurants that you
like then those restaurants might go out
of business
yeah so they're kind of like I'm erring
on the side of probably getting takeout
is good if you like places enough to
like support the businesses because you
have to think that the people that are
working there they need [ __ ] money
too and it's like a lot of the
particularly people that work in the
food industry can't really afford to sit
at home and not have a job as contagious
as this [ __ ] is if the data is correct
you're gonna catch it anyway that's what
I mean as long as you just take
precautions just just they're just
trying to slow down the rate at which
people catch me so not everybody is sick
at one time that's all they're doing
right more I think half of us at least
are gonna catch this probably but like I
said most people won't even notice yeah
it'll just be like most people that
catch it won't give a [ __ ] that they
caught it
yeah it's evidently not that bad for the
average person some people depend on how
much of that them damn virus particles
you can get because there's people shed
particles and if you get bombarded with
those damn particles you'll get really
[ __ ] sick yeah I mean super sick
which is why like I said I think it's
really smart that they're just like
limited or it was contact with one
another just trying to like mitigate it
that young dude that young doctor that
died in that Chinese hospital he was
surrounded by sick people he was just
being bombarded and it killed him he was
a young healthy dude yeah you want to
stay away from other people for a while
yeah which you know and you definitely
want to stay away from a whole bunch of
sick people Hospital man be bad place to
be in that [ __ ]
I feel bad for like the people that work
that's why they were all in a bio suits
yeah I don't blame em yeah cuz they're
just gonna be around it all day every
day just bombard and they point yes we
need them obviously because you know
there are nurses and doctors and stuff
but not fun for them not a fun time
biohazard like a [ __ ] yeah so
it's Friday and even though you know
we're like working at home everyone's
quarantine and stuff like that but I do
still like to you know do fun [ __ ] on
Friday and do fun [ __ ] on the weekend
just so I feel like I'm having something
like a normal life oh we're gonna drink
well yeah this evening we're definitely
gonna drink and
oh I want to give a shout out probably
give a shout out on the regular episode
too whenever we record it
we'll probably record it tomorrow night
actually um I want to say thank you to
Dominic yet me I just got it like
yesterday evening sent me a crustless
movie yeah I've been wanting to see that
way forever I've never seen it and sent
me hot razor and I'm like super special
edition yeah I've never seen a special
edition I haven't either
never blu-ray to both them I think yeah
yeah I'm here except we said we're gonna
have to watch it watch I got a stack of
movies this ayat people sent in yeah we
gotta still watch the Elvis movie we got
to do so who sent us to yeah that's
right we got to do nice guys it was the
one about that British thief that's
right yeah yeah so we gotta watch that
one too you so what's the man we're
gonna be like yeah drink it and I'll be
wrestling with the cat yeah you know
like she should wrestle constantly while
watching the movies
sure you get me to roll her up and damn
carpet isn't that if I have never seen
I'm sure there's like other cats out
there that are into this kind of stuff I
mean she's not a baby baby anymore like
this summer she'll be three I got this
carpet it's like a horror you know rug
he's like an oriental rug I think it's
probably where by 30 Fri a prayer rug I
don't use it as that but it's probably
rarely she goes upstairs starts
attacking it because she wants me to put
her on the ant and she waits patiently
she's she lays down like a little roll
Wow throw her out she comes rolling out
and she goes runs around duty and then
she runs around the carpet with a little
but wagon roll up slowly I hear and I
look down through the end of the tubes
around do it again do it again yeah
she's [ __ ] hilarious
she has like you know she's a little kid
she is she's like if she's like a little
you know she's a little mixed so she
just said that little stump entail
sitting there wagon and it wegg's like a
little puppy tail like her whole little
butt back when she's all excited like
I'm roll rollin rushes in their woes me
whoa roll
hahaha do it again yeah she wants to
immediately do it again she's the
craziest yeah she loves like all kind of
Russians jump on a damn rug and I'll
start dragging a rug around and running
around
[Laughter]
gotta get that on video put that we did
like a long time ago and I think you
posted on Facebook but I don't know what
happened to it like I was probably I
don't know if it's in your tablet or
something I've never seen a cat that
roughhouse like that and just like she's
like a little like a monkey she is yes
she's like a little monkey and another
thing she does too now that we're
talking about cats cuz we talk about
Beijing on yesterday's show
another thing that she does too is that
there is a little lizard that lives on
our bathroom window yeah and this same
rain in the windows as far as I know the
same lizard has lived there for like at
least two years yes and there's a frog
in there oh and the Frog loved the Frog
SS roommates a tree frog the whole tree
frog listed there as well yeah but this
lizard has lived there and he's like
pretty much always except you know when
he's out you know looking for food or
whatever day it is it's like he's
usually Ott's like sitting on other
parts of the window and Pookie is so so
excited what sholde run in the bathroom
and she'll look up there like is he home
she watches it like television yeah she
what he's like we said we call it like
Pookie TV or like TV and then she'll
like jump up on it cuz you know the
bathroom window just has like this
little narrow little ledge and she jumps
up on the ledge and then I don't know
why she does this but she goes like to
the side cuz it's very narrow and she
takes one arm like and does it like this
and like tries to get the lizard yeah
lizard Lick's adder and the lizard like
Turk can kind of see motion yeah I can
like tilt his head and like look like
what's not that big guys are doing glass
isn't clear it's like pebbles bathroom
glass yeah yeah
but it's like the the lizard like seems
like he can see her and I think the
lizard knows that she can't get him
because he doesn't move he just kind of
like does his head like yeah you can't
get me a big monster on the other side
but she I don't know why she does that
weird like stretch aren't like like
backwards
she's like trying to get it scraping is
it I'm like how many times you tried to
get it you know you can't get it you
know what I mean I don't know if she
still thinks she can get it or she's
just trying to entertain herself part of
the game or what it is but it's like she
tries to bring her in the house
sometimes cuz she'll go out of the back
porch and then she'll get one and she
tries to be all sneaky but like she'll
stick it in her mouth yeah and then run
past me and I go open the door she's
like I got captured and she lets the
lizard go and I gotta catch the lizard
in the house and then put her outside
she brought me a yellow bird but she let
go of it as soon as I opened the door
and it flew off and she looked she did
you see it if the bird was okay a little
it was like flapping klb yeah yeah
Berbers looking at me out of here oh she
relaxed her jaws another thing she
brought us she brought us this really
gross filthy ball tennis ball tennis
ball yeah that was like I'm pretty sure
like pot in a pond yeah it's not really
a pond it's just kind of like it's a
glorified puddle really I guess it's a
long bond it's one of those like ever a
little retention it's like a retention
pond and it's uh it's got fish in it you
can fish in it but yeah so she was I
guess she was over there like sitting on
the bank of it was like hey free ball
yeah then she brings it it's like really
gross and dirty and do it and she just
brought it back and she she's still
pleased with it cuz she left it in the
dirt like yeah you know the garden by
the side of her she brought it to me
show it to me and now she like back we
go stop talk about the cat though
is there anything else we need to tell
these people I'll walk them through the
apocalypse yeah I don't walk it do it
yes it's Friday we got a record smushed
up record some the matinee show a little
bit later and probably tomorrow night
which is Saturday we'll probably record
the regular show so we'll talk to you
guys again tomorrow